how's everybody doin oh it's great to
see everybody again you know actually
the Bethesda event is a few hours right
after this across the street and Phil
said to me I'm having a few friends over
why don't you stop by and look I know
Phil is really really charming but damn
he's got a lot of friends and the good
news is you're our friends too
we've had an incredible 16 year history
with Xbox going all the way back to the
original with morrowind now backwards
compatible and that goes all the way to
bringing mods to consoles with fallout 4
and now we are bringing the Fallout
universe to Xbox game pass with fallout
4 launching today
and hey since we're here we thought we'd
give all of you an exclusive world
premiere first look at fallout 76
yes fallout 76 is a prequel to all the
other games and it is our biggest one
yet it is four times the size of fallout
4 set in the hills of West Virginia you
are one of the first to emerge into an
untamed and very different wasteland
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
300 years after our great nation began
we gather together to honor the
completion of vaults 76 this sprawling
underground shelter may have been
engineered by vault-tec but it was built
by you so that if the bombs do come our
way of life will endure
almost heaven
West Virginia
it's mountain shadow
[Music]
is all bad
than the tree
young man
the mountain
like the country
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for when the fighting is stopped in the
fallout settled
you must rebuild not just walls not just
buildings but hearts minds and
ultimately America itself
[Music]
in volt 76 our future begins
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]